Professor Langdon
Hammer: Today I'm going to
try to talk a little bit more
about Elizabeth Bishop,
and I'm also going to try to
give some big perspectives on
the poets we've been reading and
also some ways of thinking about
how they fit together.
Let's look at Bishop's poem,
"Over 2,000 Illustrations and a
Complete Concordance,"
the poem placed second in her
second book called A Cold
Spring, published in
1955--the latest poems that
we'll discuss in this course.
On Wednesday I talked about
Bishop's poetics of geography or
travel as a horizontal poetics,
as opposed to the ascendant and
sublime impulses in many of the
poets that we have been
examining this term.
This poetics is ultimately a
poetry of shifting perspectives
and local perceptions.
The question that it
immediately poses is,
well: how do we put these
perceptions and these points of
view together?
The, I think,
exciting but also difficult
textures of Bishop's great
landscape poems,
"Florida," "Cape Breton," "At
the Fishhouses," "A Cold
Spring," and others,
all pose this very clearly to
us, this problem.
You might see the grains of
sand that the sandpiper searches
through in that little poem
"Sandpiper" as,
again, exemplary of this
problem in Bishop--that is,
how do we hold onto,
organize,
and find coherence in a world
of discrete and shifting
phenomena?
This is really the master
problem that Bishop addresses
very self-consciously in this
poem, "Over 2,000 Illustrations
and a Complete Concordance."
Like "The Map," it's a poem
that is in part about a
representation.
She, by implication,
begins the poem by referring to
a book, presumably the one
mentioned in the title,
"Over 2,000 Illustrations and a
Complete Concordance."
What kind of book is that?
She doesn't specify,
but as the poem unfolds there's
reason to believe it's a Bible,
I think--perhaps a family
Bible.
She says:
Thus should have been our
travels:
serious, engravable.
Our travels,
our experience in the world,
our experience of geography,
and our experience as geography
should have been,
ought to be,
serious.
It ought to add up to something.
I ought to be engravable,
something that might be bound
in book form.
The image of a book with
illustrations in a complete
concordance holds up an idea
that word and image,
perhaps word and flesh or
representation and experience,
might be bound together in a
coherent unity,
might be shown to exist in
concordance or in some kind of
correspondence.
Against this ideal or this
model of things,
where illustration and text are
bound together,
Bishop poses her own wayward
experience--her travels--which
this poem will list,
record, and give us fragments
of.
What the poem reveals to us is
a world of discrete fragments,
parts that gain meaning,
if at all, through their mere
adjacency or through the
perceiver who holds them
together--holds them together
through the quality of her
attention and the sensibility
behind it,
a form of attention for Bishop
that is always pushing towards
revelation and seeking meaning
or something beyond surface
detail but never quite arrives
there and never,
in that sense,
arrives at a place of repose or
rest or home.
Let me read the second
paragraph which brilliantly
represents the world brought
into being by this poetics of
geography.
Entering the Narrows at
St.
Johns
the touching bleat of goats
reached to the ship.
We glimpsed them,
reddish, leaping up the cliffs
among the fog-soaked weeds and
butter-and-eggs.
And at St.
Peter's the wind blew and the
sun shone madly.
Rapidly, purposefully,
the Collegians marched in
lines,
crisscrossing the great square
with black, like ants.
The poem is composed almost of
the fragments of a travel diary
or bits of a letter,
and if you read Bishop's
letters you will indeed find
observations like this on every
page.
In Mexico the dead man lay
in a blue arcade;
the dead volcanoes
glistened like Easter lilies.
The jukebox went on playing
"Ay, Jalisco!"
And at Volubilis there were
beautiful poppies
splitting the mosaics;
the fat old guide made eyes.
In Dingle Harbor…
And we jerk from one place to
another, with each sentence one
country, one spot on the map.
In Dingle Harbor a golden
length of evening
the rotting hulks held up their
dripping plush.
The Englishwoman poured tea,
informing us
that the duchess was going to
have a baby.
[This is one of Bishop's
provocative juxtapositions in
the poem.]
And in the brothels of Marrakesh
the little pockmarked
prostitutes
balanced their tea-trays on
their heads
and did their belly-dances;
flung themselves
naked and giggling against our
knees,
asking for cigarettes.
It was somewhere near there
I saw what frightened me most
of all [implying,
of course, that all of these
scenes had frightened her]:
A holy grave,
not looking particularly holy,
one of a group under a
keyhole-arched stone baldaquin
open to every wind from the
pink desert.
An open, gritty,
marble trough,
carved solid
with exhortation, yellowed
as scattered cattle-teeth;
half-filled with dust,
not even the dust
of the poor prophet paynim who
once lay there.
[Just dust.]
In a smart burnoose Khadour
[presumably their guide]
looked on amused.
Looking at this series,
this way Bishop's life seems to
add up, she continues reflecting
on the poem and on its
structure.
Everything only connected
by "and" and "and."
Open the book.
And we're back to the book now,
that ideal form of
representation in which text and
image are bound.
(The gilt rubs off the
edges
of the pages and pollinates the
fingertips.)
Bishop wants us--as in "The
Map," too--she wants the book as
something that can be held and
touched.
She's a marvelously tactile
poet.
Along with the unity of
experience that it promises to
give us is a sense of intimacy,
too, with an object.
Open the heavy book [she
says to us].
Why couldn't we have seen
this old Nativity while we were
at it?
-- the dark ajar,
the rocks breaking with light,
an undisturbed,
unbreathing flame,
colorless, sparkless,
freely fed on straw,
and, lulled within,
a family with pets,
-- and looked and looked our
infant sight away.
The Nativity is the scene of
the Incarnation,
that moment when the Word is
made flesh;
Christmas morning,
that moment when the divine
takes human form and so becomes
present in the world.
This is specifically here,
as Bishop imagines it,
a scene of revelation.
That wonderful phrase,
"the dark ajar"--as if the
shadow were a door and you could
enter it;
"the rocks breaking with
light"--that which is solid
opening.
What emerges is a flame,
a sign of spirit.
But notice how in this light,
the sacred is secularized.
What Bishop finds there is not
the holy family but "a family
with pets."
There is nostalgia here,
in this poem,
poignant and powerful;
that is, a nostalgia not so
much for the holy as for the
family once constituted by their
relation to the holy,
the family with pets but also
the family that gathered around
the book to look at them – a
family gathered through
religious practice,
who might then have "looked and
looked our infant sight away."
In that, looking expresses a
kind of primal longing for
community and for human
connection--a longing expressed
through looking,
importantly for Bishop,
which is really what the poet
is doing in "The Map,"
I think, in the way that she
invites us into her act of
looking in that poem.
Here Bishop's nostalgia is sad
but also resigned.
This Nativity is a scene that
can be remembered and looked at
from afar but not entered into,
as the belief system that it
comes out of and refers to can
be looked at from afar but not
entered into.
Bishop, as several people
remarked in section this week,
calls us back in lots of
different ways to Frost.
Frost is perhaps an unusual
place to begin a course on
modern poetry because--remember
him?
– he really is generally an
exception to the metropolitan
scene and inspiration of modern
poetry.
Modern poetry is a poetry of
the city, of the metropolis,
of the world city,
and of the place where the
world's peoples,
goods, languages,
traditions and cultures are all
"accessible,"
to use Marianne Moore's word
from her poem "New York."
Pound, Eliot,
Crane, Moore,
Hughes, and even Williams and
Stevens in their somewhat
different ways,
are all poets of the
metropolis.
The sense of ambivalence about
modernity in these poets is an
ambivalence in many ways about
the city and what it promises
and also what it in many ways
threatens us with.
Their sense of experience,
their visions of modernity and
of modern forms of community are
all located and expressed there.
Frost aggressively defines his
work against that context.
In doing this,
he links his writing to
nineteenth-century American
writing and art and links his
writing to rural culture,
which dominates the nineteenth
century.
There is an anti-modern strain
in Frost just as there is in
Yeats and, more complexly,
in Pound and in Eliot.
What's modern about Frost is
what has changed in the rural
cultures that he writes about;
that is, the collapse of
farming economies and
communities and the decay of
nineteenth-century
Protestantism,
the white church on the village
green.
You feel that loss in the
terrific aloneness of Frost's
people.
The great poem "Directive" is
about all of these things.
Frost's poetry struggles to
incorporate the secular truths
of modern science and to make
poetry, like science,
a disenchanted knowledge.
In this way,
Frost has a lot in common with
Auden, and Frost,
again like Auden,
is fundamentally concerned with
poetry as a form of knowledge,
a way to know the world.
At the same time,
poetry preserves for Frost
certain archaic,
primitive powers of
enchantment: powers associated
with primitive motives and
childhood experience that make
it a crucial alternative to
science and scientific knowing.
Think of the magic trick at the
end of "Directive" when Frost
takes us to the ruined house of
nineteenth-century culture--the
ruined farmhouse of "Home
Burial" maybe--and steals from
the abandoned children's
playhouse "a broken drinking
goblet like the Grail" and uses
it to invite us to drink from a
primal source "too lofty and
original to rage,"
that spring,
and in drinking to "be whole
again beyond confusion."
What are we drinking there then
at the end of Frost's poem,
this poem published at the end
of the Second World War?
We're drinking a kind of
elemental power that seems to
fuse language and longing and
imagination.
This is, in Frost,
a conscious rewriting,
I think, partially even a
send-up as well as a competition
with Eliot in The Waste
Land and the Grail myths
that are one of the central
motifs of that poem:
one of the central motifs that
embody for Eliot a sense of the
holy,
which is present,
however, for Eliot only through
literary allusion,
something fascinating but
unavailable as actual
experience;
something available only,
in a sense, as quotation.
Poetry in Frost,
as in Eliot,
does the work religion no
longer does.
But notice how in Frost,
in "Directive," the belief that
poetry asks from us is a belief
in a fiction,
in make-believe.
And in this Frost is strangely
and wonderfully and surprisingly
perhaps fully the contemporary
of Wallace Stevens and Hart
Crane whose work proceeds from
that same assumption.
Stevens's wartime poem "Asides
on the Oboe" begins:
The prologues are over.
It is a question, now,
Of final belief.
So, say that final belief
Must be in a fiction.
It is time to choose.
This is the theme of Stevens's
wartime masterpiece "Notes
Towards a Supreme Fiction."
And notice the contradictory
impulses in Stevens's title.
When poetry takes the place of
religion for Stevens it presents
itself as a supreme fiction,
a total representation of the
world and experience.
But we only have partial,
provisional access to that
fiction.
What Stevens gives us is merely
notes – notes,
something that Elizabeth Bishop
might present us with,
too.
In this sense,
in Stevens the shift from
religion to poetry is also a
shift from totalization,
from system to contingency and
incompletion,
to parts rather than a whole.
For Stevens,
the disappearance of the
Christian God as the center of
emotional,
spiritual, cultural life is
essentially, however,
a cause for celebration.
In Eliot it's a cause for
mourning--mourning and anxiety,
distress.
In Yeats it's a cause of
fascination and horror;
in Crane, for the making of new
myths, new metaphors.
Hughes's secular poems are
Christ-haunted.
Christ and all of the
iconography associated with him
is a source of hope and also
irony for black culture and a
reproach to the white world.
How do people,
how does culture find bearing
in a world without divine
sanction?
This is played out as an
ethical question,
a question about how to live
and act rightly in Moore and
then later in Bishop.
In general, it is a less urgent
question, a less central one in
the later poets than in the
earlier ones.
"Things fall apart;
the centre cannot hold," Yeats
says in "The Second Coming."
Bishop is fundamentally at home
in this condition,
which is a condition of
centerlessness or homelessness.
She liked the phrase "the
world's an orphan's home" in
Moore.
Bishop is at home then with a
certain kind of homelessness.
Travel is her metaphor for the
mobility of consciousness in a
world without a stable center.
Her poetry is written from the
disturbingly and disorientingly
decentered point of view that we
find already in those early
poems of hers,
a point of view that takes for
granted the absence of central
authority that religion once
provided.
Remember in "Over 2,000
Illustrations and a Complete
Concordance" that holy grave?
It's not even particularly
holy, she says.
The place of the sacred in
Bishop has been vacated.
Might poetry fill it?
This isn't a question Bishop
asks or is concerned with.
But it is, as I've been
suggesting, an urgent one in
many ways for the poets who
preceded her.
The poetry of the period 1920
through 1940,
say--really the great phase of
modern poetry-- this period is
structured,
I think, by two big questions:
how should poetry be written
and what can it do,
what can it accomplish in the
world?
In the first lecture I talked
about these different impulses
which are at once opposing but
also, I think,
related and interlocking.
I called one of them formal and
inward-turning,
an aesthetic;
the other rather outward
turning, concerned with the
moral, the political,
and the social.
The first one tends to limit
the definition of poetry to say
what is particular to this art,
to isolate what is essential to
it.
The other works to extend
poetry's scope,
to give it an expanded role in
culture, in the world,
and in our lives.
You see different versions of
both of these impulses in the
career trajectories of H.D.
and William Carlos Williams,
who begin as masters of a
certain kind of short poem and
go on to create epic poems of
cultural sweep – H.D.'s being
called Trilogy,
Williams's Paterson.
But the poet who more than any
embodies these two impulses in
the shape of his career is
Pound,
of course: as I said,
the author of the shortest and
the longest poem in modern
poetry,
the exponent of Imagism,
and the author of The
Cantos.
Imagism seems to want to get
outside of history,
to explore the "sudden
liberation… from space limits
and time limits,"
Pound says, in a kind of
autonomous aesthetic experience.
The Cantos,
however, are a poem,
as Pound called it,
"including history":
a poem of the greatest possible
range and scope and ambition.
In Imagism, there's an attempt
to establish the primary poetic
unit, to cut away what is
inessential, to find what is
true.
This is a kind of formal
program that expresses a drive
towards truth telling that we
find in somewhat different terms
in Frost and Auden and Moore.
Think of Frost's sense of fact
versus, in "Mowing," the "easy
gold at the hand of fay or elf."
Or think of Yeats's stylistic
transformation as expressed in
that short poem "A Coat" or "The
Fisherman," poems from 1915.
Think about Moore's and Auden's
severe revisions of their work,
in each case involving cutting
out poems or cutting away many
lines in order to arrive at what
Moore called,
in "Poetry," that poem
subjected to severe revision,
"the genuine."
These are all creative acts of,
I think you could say,
self-limitation and they're
linked to the general recurrent
theme in these poets – in
these poets in particular:
Auden,
Moore, Frost – to the general
theme of restraint or reticence.
"The deepest feeling always
shows itself in silence;
/ not in silence,
but restraint."
Remember Auden's stone god
"that never was more reticent,
/ always afraid to say more
than he meant."
This impulse that I'm
describing in modern poetry is
also related to formal
experiments with restraint.
You see this worked into
Moore's syllabics.
Modern poetry in many ways
seeks to restrain the singing
voice and the lyric voice of
romantic poetry as received
through nineteenth-century
poetry.
Frost's vernacular,
his will to get the "sound of
sense" into his poems functions
in this way.
So does Hughes's vernacular,
his black speech.
Think about Eliot's syntactic
and logical discontinuities and
disjunctions,
the way they interrupt and
fragment lyric utterance,
or think about Pound's
incorporation of blocks of
prose, as he did in The
Cantos.
There is in all of these
examples a tendency to define
what is modern in modern poetry
by the incorporation of
traditionally non-poetic forms
of speech and language use and,
moreover and importantly,
non-traditional methods of
organizing poetic language.
At the same time,
this impulse can be seen as a
way not of limiting or
curtailing poetry's scope,
but rather the opposite:
expanding it,
expanding it to include even,
as Moore puts it,
"school-books and business
documents," making poetry
available for people and
cultures and experience that had
not previously been represented
in poetry.
Other modern poetry is
experimental in a very different
way, indeed in its revival and
recovery and incorporation of
historical poetic forms.
You could understand Hart
Crane's reclaiming of
Elizabethan and
nineteenth-century forms of
ornamental rhetoric and
versification as exactly this
kind of reclaiming of archaic
materials.
There's something similar going
on in Pound, in Pound's recovery
of Provençal and Anglo-Saxon
verse forms, his revival of
these forms.
Pound and Crane are both heroic
poets.
They answer that question –
what can poetry do?
what can it effect in culture?
– by saying simply
"everything."
That's really the extraordinary
presumption of their long poems
– The Bridge and
The Cantos.
They are very different poets,
however, and to some extent
exposed – no,
opposed figures,
although indeed their claim for
poetry made them both exposed
figures in poignant and
complicated ways.
When I talk about their
difference, I'm thinking of
Pound's suspicion of rhetoric,
his suspicion of
representation,
and his will or drive to get
beyond these things versus
Crane's faith in rhetoric,
faith in rhetoric and
imagination, and their power to
transform the world.
In a sense, you couldn't have
two more different poets.
But both of these poets take
poetry as a kind of metaphor,
as not only a metaphor but as
the salient instance,
of the creative impulse in
history.
What makes history happen?
What makes action in history?
And they place poetry at the
center of all that is most
important that we do.
They both propose that poetry
can fulfill the central
mediating functions that
religion once did.
Pound and Crane become
cautionary figures for later
poets.
To some extent Yeats does, too;
that is, figures who seem to
show the limits of poetry
precisely in their efforts to
expand them.
This is one way we can
understand Bishop's poem,
"Visits to St.
Elizabeth's" on page 133.
This is a poem that describes
Bishop's periodic visits to Ezra
Pound in St.
Elizabeths Hospital where Pound
was institutionalized,
incarcerated,
after his return to the United
States on charges of treason.
Bishop was living in Washington
as the Poetry Consultant to the
Librarian of Congress and it
befell her almost as an official
duty to visit Pound,
hear him talk,
and bring people to Pound,
and it became the occasion for
this poem built on the form of
"This is the House that Jack
Built."
This is the poetry that Jack
made.
This is the house of
Bedlam.
This is the man
that lies in the house of
Bedlam.
This is the time
of the tragic man
that lies in the house of
Bedlam.
And she continues adding,
each time adding and,
of course, in Bishop's
distinctive manner not only
repeating but revising the terms
that she's given us;
again, a poetics of constant
readjustment.
As the poem builds,
characters are included,
not only Pound but Pound
represented as the man but also
a soldier,
a boy, and a Jew,
figures that are versions of
Pound perhaps,
reaching a climax in the final
stanza:
This is the soldier home
from the war.
[Perhaps that's Pound in some
sense.]
These are the years and the
walls and the door
that shut on a boy that pats
the floor
to see if the world is round or
flat.
[Again, Bishop touching a map.]
This is a Jew in a newspaper hat
that dances carefully down the
ward,
walking the plank of a coffin
board
with the crazy sailor
that shows his watch
that tells the time
of the wretched man
who lies in the house of
Bedlam.
It's a great poem.
I spoke of Auden's and Bishop's
perspectivism.
Here, Bishop gives us multiple
perspectives on Pound and by
extension on the social and
political ambitions of modernist
poetry.
Pound is "tragic," "talkative,"
"honored," "old," "brave,"
"cranky," "cruel," and finally
simply "wretched" – a word
that comes from "The Seafarer."
Arguably, one strain of modern
poetry ends here in 1950 in the
madhouse, in Bedlam.
Importantly though,
it is not that Bishop stands
apart form, in a position to
judge, Pound.
Instead, she is interestingly,
I think, implicated in the
scene.
She must have enjoyed,
and by her choice of title
calls attention to,
the irony that Pound is in a
madhouse that has the same name
as Bishop.
In Bishop's great war poem
"Roosters," there is a sense
that to oppose conflict out in
the world one must encounter
conflict in oneself.
Here, too, I think in multiple
ways Bishop implicates herself
in the objects of her critique
and satire.
The child's verse form,
it's important.
Bishop identifies with,
I think it's fair to say –
she's certainly interested in
– children,
throughout her poetry.
This interest points,
I think, to Bishop's sense of
herself as a minor poet;
that is, a mapmaker,
not a historian;
a poet who refuses to write the
major, culturally central,
aggressively ambitious poetry
to which modernism and,
above all, the poetry of Pound
aspired.
Auden's perspectivism in
"Musée des Beaux Arts" seems to
position the poet and poetry
similarly.
So does that famous statement
in the Yeats elegy,
"For poetry makes nothing
happen."
These poems,
"Musée des Beaux Arts" and "In
Memory of W.B.
Yeats," read like rebukes to
modern poetry's promethean
ambitions – its verticality,
if you like – and rebukes,
too, to Auden's own political
poetry of the 1930s,
exemplified by a poem like
"Spain 1937."
But, as I stressed,
Auden doesn't put a full stop
on that sentence,
"For poetry makes nothing
happen."
Rather, he punctuates it with a
colon and continues,
"it survives."
There is perhaps a double
implication here.
Either poetry does not have an
effect on the world but still
survives, despite its lack of
making something happen,
or it survives because it makes
nothing happen.
It is not a cause and it
doesn't take up causes
effectively.
What it does rather,
as Auden represents it here,
is create a space:
a space of happening,
a landscape,
and a model of the world,
seen in the same time as a
valley and a river,
the river that flows through it.
There's terrific power of
affirmation in this claim about
poetry's survival at the moment
of Yeats's death,
at the moment of the onset of
the Second World War when "all
the dogs of Europe bark."
Ultimately, in Auden,
poetry survives as "a way of
happening," as he calls it,
that is, a "way" in a sense of
both a method and a path;
and implicitly,
as I suggested talking about
this poem earlier;
it survives as a kind of open
space, a place to come into to
collect and gather in for us.
And it is figured,
I think, finally and implicitly
as a mouth, the human mouth –
open to speak old words and new
words, too.
Poetry survives in my mouth and
also in yours,
which seems like a good last
sentence to end this course
with.
So, thank you very much.